Is this too close?
Hey guys welcome to a vlog been a while. This is weird
Me and Marzia are taking a weekend going to spain and I know how it sounds like
OHOHOH *cringe*
Yeah no.. it. I don't think I've ever taken a summer holiday, so we're taking the weekend. Okay. I-i get it
"Oh, they're going. They're going to spain for a weekend." Yeah, that's right. We are
And you're coming with us! (yaay)
That's right your eyes are not deceiving you
Sandals and socks, what are you going to do about it?(kick yo azz) Send me to jail can't do nothing boii I'm comfy as fuck, boy!
[Edgar]: Don't do it! (aww i feel ya)
We're finally here, and we are right by the beach
It's super hot, It's super nice. We're going to change right away and just go down.
Uuuuuuuu
It's a lot hotter than Brighton. That's for sure. Very nice. I don't know what Marzia is doing.
I like your red
Bikini, like Baywatch.
Marzia: What?
Ah. You got the underwater camera!? It's so shallow, I can literally sit.
oooh
I'm sitting down heh-
Whoa, Jesus! Careful camera! Not waterproof. I feel like everyone is looking at me (do they know you)
Very Nice! Oh yeah boy! Yeah, Youtube man. It's hard man. Oh boy, yeah boy
*some nice music ooh*
I legit think
I'm sunburned, just like an hour, that's how you know you're swedish, also
We haven't done a room tour this is our safe where we keep all our important stuff (what stuff pewds?)
Very nice. This is our phone
We can make calls with. very nice. This is a chair. We can sit, very nice(wow)
Sunset is happening right now (omg you're so bootyful poods)
Let's have a look at this beautiful view that is actually gorgeous.
Look at that boy. That's the- this is the money shot. I think about something will be so now we're
We're at the Beach again
*Marzias hehe*(so cute, man, beautiful)
I'm not a wahmen. What are we doing now Marzia. [Marzia]: We are going to dinner!
I don't know why I keep doing these. [Marzia]: Have you been doing it on mines as well? [pewds]: Yeah!
It's so attractive
There was something bad in my lunch. I still feel my lunch...no one cares
Everyone cares about Marzia's dress more you're right
So beautiful isn't she the most beautiful woman in the world(you're both bootyful trust me)
Hell no, you need help?(WHY NOT)
[Marzia]:You see these shoes? [Felix]: You need a hand girl?
Marzia: Yeah
[Marzia]: Jeff. Wha- ha! Jeff! [Pewds]: I knew it!
We just had dinner it was ve-very nice and now we're going to watch
the season Finale of-. Marzia:???
What's it called the anime?
[Marzia]: Ma... [Pewds]: Makasomos revenge or whatever...thats not what its called
"Masamune-Kun's Revenge" (it's good)
Yep, na, NAYY NANAN
There you are. What are you doing? We have to Go it's a new day(LET ME SLEEP HOOMAN)
Same vlog, we're going to this city center of Majorca. Majorca? wherever we are
So bright here. Jesus christ
Mainorca and then we're heading back just to chill again. I like those people standing out there. [Fake man]: What do we do Barrett
[Barret]: I don't know man I guess we just keep standing here.
I guess we do(oh)
Alright, now. We're in *Wind blocks out sound* looks like the Washington monument *More wind* pretty coo-woah
I'm Getting all wet. What's happening. It's super windy and I guess we're just gonna check out the city
(The butt wow)
What are you doing (WHY IS THIS CENSORED)
Look at this, Cathedral. It's beautiful. look at the
look at the Windows. I paid five euros for this
That's pretty. To be fair, got my man J-dog over here. Jesus christ, seem familiar
This is what it's like being around Marzia
I'm just walking down this hallway. Just chilling relaxing, relaxin
I wonder where Marzia is?(in your heart and soul)
Where could she have gone I see you, okay? Whoa it's cold
damn
my favorite
2014 Brazil
You're ready to lose Marzia?
Okay, here we go
Jesus Christ! She almost hit me. Just I want one good one
its so windy, I'll blame the wind. Yeah
You should throw yourself (laughs). I think that's as good as it gets
it's way too hot
To be a Swede here man. What. Oh man you see the sand it's so windy. I see the sand flying(high)
I see it. I'm so sunburned I feel it. I feel it marsh we're going to rent a boat
[mariza]: its not a boat
It looks..if it goes in the water, what is it then? [marzia]: its a pigolo. [pewds]: It's a pigolo everyone. I have 5% life battery
Then I die. We are on one of these. Marzia I'm the captain get your-, so it has a thing on top of it.
Marzia: Are you gonna go up?
I'm 100% Gonna go. I'm about to go on the slide
This is going to be pretty scary man
so first I got to moisturize it
maximum moisture
Marzia: Ah- careful! It's so-uhuh [Poods]: U ready? [Marzia]: YEAH!
I'm scared. I don't wanna do it
Haha. Yeaaaaaah!
No! Stop I change my mind. Oh shit!
marzia: you went down with the bucket?
Did i look cool? [Marzia]: I don't know
Save the bucket. [Marzia]: I will
*grunts* the bucket
How deep do you think the water is?
Right. So deep man
How do I get up on this?
Use the stairs
my ass is hanging out
Alright time to see how sunburned I got ...oh
What happened here?(bioShock)[marzia]: you mean how NOT sunburned you got?
What happened here?
What is this?
Why do I look like Rick, my hair is perfect. I don't think I ever looked this good
Jeff. Heeeeeey look at youuu. Let's go have dinner boi
We just had some dinner and now. Cake!{the way you look at marzia, pewds)
Did I get sunburned? No you didn't (shut up about sunburn u didnt)
Oh my god they're massive
Whoa hey chump, what is happening?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa what?
What the hell was that?! God!
Poor lobsters, Now I feel terrible I'll never eat lobster again
[marzia]: i thought that was the moon
(lol its a lampost), wow it does look actually even on camera? It looks like it
We just walked back to the hotel. What is happening?
Okay, all right guys that was our weekend in Majorca (mainorca/menorca), wherever we are thank you for coming along
So long Farewell Auf Wiedersehen goodbye
Boy, she never watched sound of music its disgusting